here in the u.s there appears to be a
major escalation in the federal
investigation into former president
trump's actions after the 2020 election
scott mcfarland has more on this story
from capitol hill scott good morning to
you
gail good morning more than 30 people
associated with the former president
have received federal grand jury
subpoenas some of them in the past week
and at least two of them
had their phones seized as well
multiple knowledgeable sources tell cbs
news the investigation branches into at
least three areas the alleged attempt to
submit fake electors to overturn the
2020 election also the money
raised and see are spent to overturn the
election by trump's super pac save
america pac as well and finally into
trump's stop the steel rally january 6th
meanwhile there's a new development in
the federal investigation of those
records seized from mar-a-lago last
month the justice department and the
trump legal team
agreeing yesterday that federal judge
raymond deary would be an acceptable
selection to be the independent special
master in that case which is important
because yesterday the trump legal team
again asked a federal judge to freeze
the criminal investigation of those
records until the special master
concludes his or her work
tony
scott mcfarland staying on top of it for
us scott thank you very much